for avengers infinity war the russo
brothers managed to successfully juggle
a jam-packed star-studded cast of
characters without overwhelming anybody
in the process
that being said infinity war did leave a
few characters sidelined
some such as ant-man and hawkeye were
completely absent
while others made only relatively brief
appearances
the hulk fell into the latter category
and while the big guy was mostly
overshadowed by his alter-ego bruce
banner after his early defeat at thanos
hands
he surely won't be out of action for
much longer here's why
and hulk
smash
inner demons the hulk we saw in infinity
war was clearly struggling with his
inner demons
not least the shame of his initial
encounter with thanos
dude you're embarrassing me from the
wizards as it turns out however there's
actually a lot more going on too
as co-director joe russo explains on the
infinity war commentary i think
ultimately what it is is that
he's tired of playing hero to uh bruce
banner
one way or the other hulk's
unwillingness to participate in the
events of infinity war was a crucial
part of both his
and banners character arcs this has only
been a good thing for the hulk's legacy
in the wider mcu
as fascinating as banner's struggles can
be the on-screen hulk has been a little
too one-dimensional character for a
little too long
this twist should bring some new depth
to a character who for many
is regarded as little more than a big
green wrecking ball
and avengers 4 is as good a chance as
any to solidify hulk's legacy as a
three-dimensional character
jekyll meets hyde in 2018 mark ruffalo
hinted at a rocky future for the
relationship between bruce banner and
the hulk
and the only one who banner probably
dislikes more than anything else
is hulk and they're headed for a
showdown
that showdown he mentions never really
occurred in infinity war leaving the
door wide open for these warring
personalities to clash in avengers 4.
between ruffalo's remarks about a hulk
banner showdown and the russo statements
about hulk getting tired of bailing out
banner avengers 4 could even be the
point at which the mcu gets its first
taste of professor hulk
a character created in the comics when
hulk and banner united into a single
personality
combining the latter's brains and the
former's brawn
avengers 4 concept art leaked in 2018
depicting the hulk in an avengers team
outfit would seem to back up this
possibility
running the gauntlet some fans have
suggested that in avengers 4
tony stark will end up going back in
time gathering up past versions of the
infinity stones along the way
in order to build his own infinity
gauntlet and if he succeeds
it stands to reason that somebody with a
fair amount of heft is going to be
needed to wield it once it's made
the idea that this gauntlet slinging
giant could be hulk becomes even more
appealing when you take a professor hulk
scenario into consideration
if the hulk and banner do join forces
and dawn an infinity gauntlet it's hard
to imagine that it wouldn't be a
powerful enough combo to put thanos out
of action once and for all
a one-sided fight another avengers 4
rumor posits that at some point during
the movie the hulk will end up losing an
arm
but let's be completely honest here it's
not like he'd be the first do i look
like iron man stark
i'm sorry i'm so oh i'm sure that's
gonna be okay
so what could possibly happen that would
lead to earth's greenest hero losing his
arm
three words stark's infinity gauntlet if
the hulk were to take on thanos gauntlet
against gauntlet
it would stand a reason that the only
way to win would be the removal of the
opponent's gauntlet
by whatever means necessary take all
these pieces and put them together
and you get a picture of banner and hulk
uniting into professor hulk
wielding an infinity gauntlet against
thanos and losing an arm in the process
wild conjecture you bet but then again
so is basically everything else
surrounding avengers 4 right now
the story's in we may not know much
about what marvel has planned for
whatever happens after infinity war but
we do know that the hulk's carefully
developed story arc has been one of the
most compelling
and crucial elements of the late stage
mcu
mark ruffalo has made it clear in the
past that we've been watching an
entire hulk story taking place
throughout thor ragnarok
avengers infinity war and avengers 4.
avengers 4 constitutes the third act in
that arc
typically where the hero faces his fears
earns redemption
and wins a great victory this movie
won't just be the conclusion of the
fight against thanos and the culmination
of the first chapter of the mcu
but also the climax of the hulk's
unofficial trilogy 2.